first when Timbuktu was occupied by JD's
one year's occupation and I read every
day in the newspaper about hostage but
all time it was European ostrich
it was journalist who was kidnapping to
us some time French American person
nobody talked about 1000 people who live
and was frustrated every day by this
occupation for me the concept of victim
is very strange concept because people
talk a lot about the victim mostly if
the victim will resolve what you say no
like and for me to was very important to
talk about victim who not nobody talk
the courageous woman who refused to put
refuse to cover and people who play the
football without borne the music war
forbidden but people sing slowly in the
cellar silence and it's very important
to to believe that humanity have a
strong capacity to to fight the
victories is come not only from the army
army of course can liberate etc and for
me it was very important to talk about
my community who believe who is the
Muslim they pray every day more than to
the villa and they have completely
different concept of Islam than that
those people who come it's important how
they protect Islam and when you never
talk about those people in the TV in the
newspaper and you talk only about the
crazy person who use the way like you
talk is terrible it means we don't have
the capacity to manage our world but you
when we met in my return you told me
then that those youngsters who start
playing football without a ball it's a
very powerful image about the resistance
through culture about resistance I mean
you know which talk about Dostoyevsky
that beauty can save the world
I mean that's the thing what is
extremely important for you
why because beauty is come from any
culture yes
beauty nobody had the monopoly of beauty
the beauty comes from not only from Bach
or Mozart but if you to come from the
place we'll never know who compose the
song that is also beauty beauty comes
from the people also who don't have her
own painter compositor bet every day
every morning they dress like Pantera
that is very important to understand
that culture is mean not only the
official culture cultures not only in
the museum or in the theater beauty is
everywhere and it's very important to to
know that and to say that for me beauty
beauty it's really what you have spirit
if you have some field you can share and
tell and I was completely fascinated by
Russian culture it was music it's
theater from anything but I didn't know
before that but I accept
and I keep that many thing I keep I
cannot to put to my work to the cinema
and to do the movie like that but you
see the quintessential European question
what haunts us since the world of
totalitarianism and what's the question
of Adorno and Benjamin and Steinem any
others that the world of beauty that the
world of the Arts that the world of the
human these did not protect us from the
world of Bob instead I mean that's the
awful thing that the greatest
perpetrators indeed were you know
educated intelligence people they knew
their real girl and so on and so forth
so and that's look I am very much
impressed by what you you know what you
show us on body how simple resistance
can be to the power of barbarians that
reason all the power which is stronger
than their power yet at the same time we
know that in straightaway did not work I
mean this whole world of humanities
collapsed in the eyes of barbarism but
but for me it's really interesting about
the definition of barbarian and the
barbarism is not to have the capacity to
resolve our problem today
you know we build no let me finish we
built several years ago war between two
Berlin
and this all was and we continuous today
to build war and we forget because the
departed that is this world we built
today cannot eat this for a long time
yes for me the reaction against any war
we build even in méditerranée the build
war because power people want to yeah
and the gains of this world we need to
create something different that this art
can help that well there we are hearts
the intellectuals culture can it help us
I would I would I would be careful but
culture as in up just I'll say briefly
as an opponent of evil because culture
has been used very beautifully and
effectively by all kinds of evil regimes
by Hitler by Stalin by by many others
and as you said a minute ago there's a
way in which what some of the finatus
the the Islamic fanatics now do is try
to create it's a kind of art it's a kind
of performance art what they what they
do with television with culture in a way
culture a little bit like the Internet
and the social media is is morally
neutral I mean it's a it's a way we have
of communicating in a way we have of
creating you know the question is what
are the politics and the values behind
it and that that's more important than
the objects its itself I think culture
can give us courage courage to hold on
our dreams and our aims but not my aims
other aims of our effort larger and it's
it's a simple fact culture as a tool
thinking is a tool and intellectuality
is a tool and this night we saw high
intelligent crimes and so i think we
should be a bit careful to have too much
hopes in thing
or in culture it's a dream of the 18th
century it's the dream of enlightenment
if we find the courage to use our own
understanding if we find the courage to
focus on the good the truth and
beautiful in the end we will be better
how about our world and the better man
but this theory is over 200 years old
now and I think it did and does not work
so good so I come from the 18th century
myself so I am admirer of the
Enlightenment but we have to remember
that there's only one philosopher who
told us that thinking is something so
special that it is beyond good and evil
that the thing itself the intelligent
human itself is the highest possible
thing and this was Martin Heidegger
a Nazi philosopher so I think we will
make a better deal believing that
thinking is a tool and you can use a
tool for very different names
you